all right Glenn Glenn where'd you grow
up where are you from originally from a
small town called Rialto California in
the city and the County of San
Bernardino
and tell me about your family you had
both your parents uh I had ever since I
had an adopted father and I had my
biological mother and uh my sister my
Six Sisters I'm the only boy in the
family so there's seven of us
where was your
biological dad my bicycle father uh come
to find out
um
he was in prison for using a 17-year
stretch for a Mass lottery on the police
officer
do you know anything about your father
um did you ever meet him I met him I met
him
um a few years when I was like 21 years
old
I actually uh I got into some trouble
out here in California and I'm uh uh the
only place I can get away with is Iowa
Storm Lake Iowa
he asked where he was at he was working
for a Tyson company Tyson a meat company
and that's where I was at you know what
I mean I went out there until things
blew over out here in California and
then I went back
but yeah he's a converter my father's a
convict and uh
he's no longer a pro probation but he uh
he is on federal probation you know what
I mean
how would you describe your childhood
ah it was rough it was rough being the
only boy in my family
um
I I felt like all my sisters got
everything before I did you know what I
mean uh I'd be the first one first
enough for school the last one out
because they'll be you mean they'll be
bullying me in the restroom and stuff
you know I mean but if I could if I
could really nine out of 10 I'd probably
get my childhood on a seven a seven
anyway I started being fun you know I
mean and then things went bad yeah
things went bad my uh my stepdad was
abusive and uh as far as abusive I'm
talking about beating me like I was like
I was a grown man you know what I mean
yeah getting two by four and wherever it
landed I'm getting hit
and uh you know broken bones a couple
broken noses and you know because he was
just backhanded me or I mean he's old
school he's from uh I don't know if
you're familiar with it it's uh
Michoacan Mexico
so his old school like he's old school
Mexican like it's malware the highway
type of deal like you can't tell him I
love you because he thinks you're a
[ __ ] or something I mean you can't give
him a hug because that's not what men do
you shake your hand you know what I mean
or you just acknowledge them with the
with the what's up you know what I mean
but uh very abusive you know that's a
sense to her
um dude why you got all these bridges on
you oh I fell or I mean we were
wrestling or you know I mean like you
don't have no brothers like who you
wrestling with
oh I think my sister is like okay
whatever I mean it's your point to the
teachers noticed um he pulled my my he
pulled I don't know back in the day he
was I don't know if it was coming but my
little uh let's get Cypress Cypress he
pulled it so hard to where his whole
side was bald
you mean and you can tell so uh the
teachers always say what happened here
uh
uh are you okay and all my parents don't
hit me they said I'm lying I mean but my
whole body's full of bruises you know
what I mean
but I mean I had a lot for my for my
from my stepdad you know
you feel like that has affected your
adult life in any way uh I think that's
who I think it's made me strong enough
to to to
to not be like him you know I mean um I
have kids myself and I've never
disciplined my kids and my kids don't
know what it is if you can ask my kids
has your dad ever hit you has your dad
ever put his hands on you you'll be like
no
I mean my dad has never hit me um
um how's your day discipline you all you
have to do is look at me I know I'm
doing something wrong you know what I
mean so that's pretty cool you know what
I mean
it is
but you got into trouble yeah I got into
some trouble uh at a young age
um
at a young age it was out of five of us
four of us got caught I was the fifth
one I got away uh I got four of my my
friends my best friends doing back from
prison to this day
for uh uh for you know growing up we
didn't know no better we were a bit
racist to the blacks and we burned their
house down and
I mean I say this without prejudice and
I hope it doesn't come to come back and
ask but yeah we burned our house down in
a couple of a couple of them passed away
you know what I mean
and uh uh and I said there was four of
us and
it was five of us and four of us got
caught I'm the one that got away I'm the
one that got sent to Iowa
I mean
and then uh as an adult uh I picked up a
couple of some battery chargers uh
picked up a couple gun charges and um
he's spiral I mean downhill after that I
mean I did 11 years in prison
straight for uh involuntary maths letter
um I got in a fight
um knocked the dude out dude hits the
floor
and I've been known to the fact he had a
brain aneurysm
you mean I'm not knowing this until 11
years later till I put my appeal in
um the doctors for the for the autopsy
and they're like well what's this
uh I say brain aneurysm
so
he was already dying I mean well yeah
and the dude's like objection your honor
no I was just honors like sustained you
know keep talking like this the judge
didn't even know nothing about this I
didn't know anything about this you know
so I'm sitting in jail for I'm sitting
in prison for I'm looking at I'm already
doing life my life they gave me a life
sentence and I'm doing life and my Sally
as a matter of fact
um can I see it because can I say his
name all right uh there's Julio Costa
from Orange County he's a lifer
he was like look bro uh I'll help you
with your appeal you know what I mean
I'm like nah man for what dude like
forget about that man they they gave me
what they gave me already well behind my
back he feels in my he feels out my
appeal paperwork
they called me one day they're like hey
Taurus roll it up you're going uh out to
court I'm in prison already I'm in
calipat a four yard
um uh gangsters Killers murderers you
name it I mean uh you name it the
Mansion the the Manson Brothers I'm
there you know what I mean uh
sure I was matching to me he was my
neighbor for uh another minute so I'm
like I'm uh Richard Ramirez I got I was
able to meet him in prison
um the I don't know if that's really The
Night Stalker from from L.A County
so I come out to court and um
sure enough uh uh I'm in court for like
two months I mean doing disappear and
I'm mad and the whole time I met him I
said like this [ __ ] like you
mean it went behind my back like
hey I mean it's just it's a process
going back and forth to to court you
know I mean so the day comes to where
they uh they it should be trial and uh
my mom's there the whole family's there
and
I haven't seen I haven't seen my mom and
dad about uh my mom and my sisters in
about 11 years
you know what I mean and uh I've only
been able to talk to him on paper you
know because calipat's far it's over
Centennial it's over there by Ironwood
by Mexico it's pretty far
and uh so I was like don't treat Mommy I
mean I'll be home soon you know 11 years
ain't nothing it's a decade
you mean uh
she she has strong belief you're coming
home you're coming home you're coming
home
my life was already my mind was was said
I'm doing life in prison that's it I
mean that's that's all I'm doing like I
love you guys but
uh if you guys do coming back and forth
for physics I'm gonna get weak and I'm
not gonna be able to do this you know
what I mean
so my study like I said is supposed to
be on my back so it fills out the appeal
paperwork they call me the court
attorneys are going out to court I mean
all right
um so I brought the court come back all
the way down here to West Charlotte
Detention Center
um right here in San Bernardino County
and I've seen it for about two like two
and a half months
um going back and forth to court they
come to deliberate and uh you guys come
to agreement yes uh we the jury finally
defended not guilty of a first degree
murder
um but we found him guilty for uh count
two and three of uh involuntary
manslaughter
uh this is the first degree
um time served
and I was like time surge what does that
mean they're like you're going home you
know I look back on my attorney
you're okay you're okay
um yanish is uh Mr Torres
well
you know you've done 11 years now and uh
the jury finds you not guilty of uh
first degree murder will find you guilty
of involuntary maths letter at the first
degree
uh with time serve
so uh
this this matters dismissed Mr Torres
and go look on the streets you know
that's how that was
you mean um how'd you feel dude oh my
gosh dude I was um I mean by by the time
I thought cars were flying and all kinds
of stuff you know I mean you mean you
don't know you don't know what you think
when you're wearing behind the wall and
you haven't seen Society in such a long
time
you know what I mean like I'm saying
excuse me I'm I'm eating really fast at
the dinner table you know what I mean
I'm taking too many showers and uh you
know my mom was like son and relax you
know I mean like you don't you don't
have to live like that I'm like I know
Mom I'm just used to it you know what I
mean
um I'm reading books I'm playing chess
I'm working out every day and um my mom
catch my mom looking at myself crying
like damn that's my son like
but if you do to him you know what I
mean like but it's it's just something
that gets installed in you in the United
States yeah it's at a young age and
especially being in prison I had to just
break them Anatomy bro I mean that's it
I mean I had to break the monotony and I
did and I mean I beat the system and I
came home
so I mean what kind of things were you
doing before you got into trouble with
well because before before I landed in
prison uh I traveled you know I mean I
was traveling and like I said I went to
uh uh I met my father in Iowa Storm Lake
Iowa I visited uh Chicago
um uh Omaha Nebraska uh Billings Montana
Seattle Washington
Seattle Washington is cool the pike is
is I love it
um the last place I landed before I came
back to California was Vegas
and if you're not familiar with Vegas
there's a summer land Henderson
excuse me Las Vegas Nevada and it's a
little thing they're called Naked City
um I mean people aren't walking around
naked but it's it's what they call the
area because it's infested with
prostitutes drugs
sex drugs and rock and roll you know
what I mean
so uh my cousin uh Crystal rest in peace
she was living there she had a three
bedroom apartment there and uh
so it's a late night about three o'clock
in the morning and every every
convenience store has has a has a uh uh
slot machines so you mean I'm at the
same level I'm playing slot machine
and you know five dollars here five
dollars there I'm I'm drinking a beer I
mean they don't care
so uh I don't know where the door opens
someone's walking in and I hear ah
and I'm like
so you mean the the dude's looking like
what happened I'm not gonna I'm not
gonna help her you love her so I'm like
of course so I go Hopper I put my tape
on you know what I mean uh just for your
speech I'm just playing so I run over
there
and this this black dude I'm not gonna
lie this I mean I'm not trying to get
racial or nothing but this black dudes
holding on to this girl
and she's playing tug of war like let me
go let me go help me yeah you could tell
she's like
not American because she her English is
broken
but she's like help me help me help me
so I run up and I I I I I you mean I was
separate I separate them and I go hey
bro you know back the [ __ ] up I'm sorry
can I say that on camera uh it broke
back up a little bit I mean uh uh
obviously the girl right here doesn't
want to message you you know what I mean
and then uh he was like hey bro like all
right if she's yours [ __ ] you can have
her you know what I mean I'm like yeah
She's Mine He's Mine He's My he's my
husband he's telling me I'm like your
husband he's like your husband
uh yes my wife all right all right well
you guys have a good night
so are you okay are you okay oh my God
thank you or I mean she's pretty dude
like she is so this girl is so gorgeous
I'm like dude
I'm like I need that and I mean like I I
need that like like can you can you come
to my house can I go to your house
oh I need a drink oh I got you don't
worry about it I got you a drink
and uh we get back to her house dude and
uh
Reviving she takes her she takes uh she
takes her shirt off and uh she's walking
to her house in a bra he has these
little booty shorts on
and the music the Damned and I'm like
yeah I'm about to get it in dude like
you know what I mean he's a beautiful
woman
and uh his drugs leads you to you know
what I mean uh uh
and uh uh pretty much you don't think
you know I mean when you're under the
influence and uh
so I go hey uh you know before we go
before we do anything because she sits
on my lab dude so she's in front of me
her boobs are right here and I'm looking
at her I'm sitting
I said look before we go anywhere I just
want to let you know that um
I mean thank you for for allowing me to
be here right now and opening the doors
oh no I'm proud of you you saved my life
I could we pay you you know I could pay
you and sucky sucky and I'm like
oh cool I'm not worried about it let me
just say you want to repay me that's
what's up
and uh so I keep reaching dude I keep
reaching and she's like stop
and I can reach it I'm like stop
and then uh she gets you up off of me
bro
and she tells me uh are you sure you you
want this and I said yeah hell yeah I
like this you know
and she says uh okay
you can't be mad I should man and I'm
like oh God if he's gonna tell me you're
a dude
and she's like no
I do I'm only a dude from the waist down
and I said what
she goes yeah are you serious she said
yeah uh
uh oh can I see you know I mean can I
just are you you got to be [ __ ] me
can I can I see you know what I mean she
said sure
so she she bends over bro and all I see
is nut sacks and I'm like oh my God oh
my God all right I've seen enough
I've seen enough and I'm like I mean I'm
like oh you know it's okay it's okay
honey you're not gay you're not gay
you're okay
uh so you still wanna you still want me
to uh you still want this and I said no
I said without the respect that I don't
want this you know I mean uh I go but
you know we could be friends
and she said okay you spend the night
and and and and and can I sucky sucky
still I said no none of that none of
that like you know I like women and she
said Okay I I have a I have a lot of
women friends uh tomorrow I introduce
you okay
so I spend the night bro that's cool
she's cool she's real respectful her
name's Anna bro
um she lives in Vegas off of Van Patten
and uh um that's called Naked City it's
right behind the Riviera
a little house is right there right
behind the Rivera and uh
so I'm there dude I've been drinking so
I didn't wake up to like 11 like 11
o'clock in the morning so I wake up and
there's a bunch of women there
you mean just coming home from doing
their thing and
they're all [ __ ] dude you know what
I mean I'm beginning to the fact they're
all [ __ ] and there's only one girl
there
her name is Maria that's uh that's our
woman you know what I mean
and Maria is probably by far the sexiest
from the ball you know what I mean so I
said I should totally respect I said are
you trying to tune oh no honey I'm my
woman you know I mean she shows me you
know what I mean I'm like okay cool
I go what's the deal and she goes all
these women you know I mean they uh
they're called Renegades they they're
women they're uh ex-prostitutes that run
away from their pants
you know what I mean that's what they
call them Renegades and um so they have
no title they their work their
Freelancers they work for themselves
and but if if their pimp sees them
um it's called being snatched up they
get snatched up again so they because
they belong to their that organization
they belongs to that pimp
but
if okay say say you're a pimp and you
have a bunch of girls but you got one
girl that keeps looking at me
and I look at her and I said what's up
man you know what I mean why are you
looking at me like that
you mean it's called Reckless eyeballing
now that girl becomes my girl because
she's staring at me you mean she
respects you as you as your pimp she's
gonna look at the floor or not or or
Look Away not not look at no other man
you know
and it's called Reckless eyeballing
so I don't know nothing about pimping
dude I I don't know nothing about none
of that you know what I mean but these
girls
I'm their manager you mean they caught
it
all right cool so uh it went from
hey I'm done here come pick me up or hey
can you hold the door for me I'm coming
out to her like hey um
um let's go to the cars on the ship
we're gonna get you a car
wow you're gonna get me a car like just
are selling their bodies to get me a car
bro you know what I mean
um so uh they buy me a Mercedes
I became their pimp dude
um full blown their pimp but I wasn't
taking uh I wasn't taking all their
money I mean it was 70 30s they would
keep 70 percent I would keep 30. you
know what I mean and it wasn't because I
asked for it it was because
I don't want their money bro they put in
all that work they they sacrificed their
body or however uh for them to just give
it up for free you know what I mean and
I'm like you know what no just uh I I'll
take 30 just for being your bodyguard
now that was my title I'm a bodyguard
I'm a body guard all I do to hear her
pant dude you know I'm a bodyguard
so um
a couple of friends from Cali come over
and uh
they're like bro man you got a bunch of
women right here bro like what's up with
them you know
so uh I gotta I got a picture I'll show
you one day uh hopefully we we establish
a relationship to where I can I'll show
you to where they have a you know those
big old couches they used to they used
to that turn like that but they connect
you can make a horseshoe out of them
well uh I have a picture and all my
homies all my friends from California
are there about five of us and there's
about 17 girls right all with no shirts
on and that were like this feeling like
real players right literally they know
all these girls are transvestites you
know what I mean uh
but yeah that lasted for about um that's
about uh about two years dude and uh
I hate and then I hit uh I mean I went
gambling one day and I hit that I hit
the Rivera and I hit him for 180 000.
I mean a slot machine and uh
well Vegas says this thing you can't
leave you can't leave the state of Vegas
without more than ten thousand dollars I
mean you gotta invest it into stocks and
bonds
it's it's what they do or you invest
into the casino
that way whenever you go back to casino
it's you go from being a mirror nobody
to Mr Torres or Mr Jackson or whatever
whatever your name whatever your last
name is
um uh uh full-blown benefits you know
what I mean and that's what I had
so
Vegas is a Vegas is a mob City bro I
mean I tell you that much uh because
when you think nobody's watching
somebody's always watching and um so I
come back
so they'll tell me you want to get
escorted to your car and I said no I'm
fine I got this you know what I mean
about an hour passes and I noticed I
noticed uh you know you could tell
people are watching you
and I I looked I look and I'm like damn
it that dude wasn't there before
I'm like dancing wasn't there before and
this girl sitting next to me but she
keeps putting her hands on my legs and
I'm like I'm like
I don't even know this girl I'm like hey
can I help you
and she was like no you know I just
think you're actually just think you're
hot and I'm like okay well can you keep
me asking yourself because my leg is hot
you know what I mean
and she was like so she starts playing
on my leg and I'm like
excuse me
um
I'm like what's your name
she said Maribel I said okay Maribel um
what's going on
what are you doing here she goes uh well
you know I'm here watching this
beautiful this is I'm here with watching
this beautiful guy you know what I mean
uh uh play his games and and I go yeah
which one he goes you silly
and uh uh and I go yeah and for some
reason I went like this and my face gets
slapped into the machine bam and I mean
like boom
so when I look back
I just it was a wrap my lights went out
you know what I mean
all I remember is is is a little sketch
of of my face
uh
I don't know if I was in a van I don't
know if but my face is getting drugged
like a grinder
on the asphalt in Las Vegas and this my
whole face I have pictures I'll show you
one day uh my whole face my whole like
this whole face the whole the whole side
right here is is getting grinded on the
floor because they want to know where
the rest of my money's at
and I'm like I don't know I don't know I
don't know
I go out
I'm out I don't remember nothing
um I didn't wake up
chill but I want to say 10 30 11 30 in
the morning
because the sprinklers broke me up at
the Rivera
um you know how they have bushes and
stuff all around the Rivera well they
found me on the third
the third uh the third uh
uh parking stall in the bush in there
you know what I mean I was like they
threw me in the bush
so the guy the guy that the parking
security he was like hey are you all
right are you okay I hear him
hey buddy are you okay and I'm like yeah
so when I get up
I see his face like oh my God
you know I'm like I'm like what dude and
he was like oh my God like he was like
like trying to I'm like dude like what's
wrong with you I got something on my
face and he's like
he's like look at the mirror look look
at look at the mirror and I'm like all
right so I look in the mirror and I'm
like
what the hell this whole like from like
my face right here all this right here
all this all this all this
is meat red like meat red all the skin
was and that's what it was when I was I
remember like
like bouncing my face on on the on the
floor getting in my whole face is
getting grinded bro
I mean like you know where's the rest of
the money man and I'm like oh [ __ ]
that's what that was
and uh
I'm like [ __ ] I don't know dude I don't
know what happened
so uh uh I get up I have no shoes on bro
no shoes on and Vegas is hot I don't
know if you've ever been to Vegas but
it's hot hot bro it's ugly hot
and I'm walking around barefooted so I'm
like ah ah
we're like oh [ __ ] I break it luckily um
I'm I'm right here at the Rivera and Van
Patten is uh about a street away dude so
so uh vampires about a street away so I
get there fast
and uh
my cousin remember I tell you my cousin
crystals out there
and she's like oh my God cousin what
happened to you
and I was like is it that bad she's like
oh my God look at yourself
and I I went I looked at myself and I
was crying dudes I was just like what
the hell what the hell is going on am I
gonna explain this one and that's where
my phone rings
foreign
I
was like I don't know Mom she goes no
you're not staying there no more I'm
gonna send you money and come back to
California
and uh all right cool so my mom sends
you money I come back to California
what have you done since you got home uh
whatever just got home
um
I got a I got a job in the union
um with my dad my dad there's a
superintendent for for Canby homes
my mom's an interpreter for right here
for CCB uh La criminal course building
um I do construction I'm certified
electrician well well I was doing my 11
years I got my culinary arts degree and
I got I got my Master's in uh in
Psychology so that's pretty cool that's
great you know what I mean but yeah good
for you yeah but you're staying on the
streets now uh currently yes I'm I'm
back and forth on the streets because uh
you know I'm not gonna can I say this on
camera without prejudice um I had a drug
habit you know what I mean and uh it
takes a totally me sometimes and and I
can't blame the devil for everything you
know what I mean I gotta blame I gotta
blame myself I mean because we're in
control of my actions
and uh so me having my drug problem I I
tend to seclude myself because everybody
I know doesn't do drugs
I mean so they know where you've been at
or you don't don't do that to yourself
don't isolate yourself it's because they
know
I'm going on a spiral again or I'm
self-loathing or I mean
um I'm thinking like why why me why did
I get out I mean I should be doing life
in prison you know what I mean and
because that's my mind was wrapped
around like okay this is my life now I
mean I was getting to the point where I
was gonna get tattooed everything my
whole face my whole body and
my mom said uh you're coming home just
just just don't know when but you're
coming home just know that
I mean this is where I'm at now you know
what I mean talking to you and and being
blessed and being being blessed and able
to have this conversation with you means
a lot to me so thank you sure thank you
so much what is your drug Now what is my
drug uh I drink um I I drink alcohol I
smoke weed and methamphetamine you know
what I mean
but uh
thank God I I can I can say no I can
walk away from that and say no no uh uh
being that I'm Dreaming I'm strong in
the Lord I believe in God and uh my
sister I don't know if you're familiar
with but they're uh
really Plugged In With Victory Outreach
in uh Victorville
and uh
I did I hit the little I did a little
program for about a year
I mean we may come in off the streets
and a bunch of drug addicts ex-gang
members and just
let go and let God you know what I mean
and and I did that for about a year
but I got scared because I I started to
get in tune like really in tune I got it
I got I had to
uh
I guess my gift was the to interpret
tongues and what people here
it was like
uh it was like English to me you know
what I mean and it's just pretty it was
pretty gnarly bro to it scared me so I
like walked away from it
you know what I mean what is the hardest
part to transition from spending a
decade in prison and then thinking
you're going to be there forever and
then being popped out on the street
but it's just it's really hard it's
really hard
institutionalized right yeah you're
sitting your ways already to as far as
you're confined to is eight by ten
and you're just shooting another man and
sharing this eight by ten meaning every
time you got stress each other you're
bump into each other you're bumping
excuse me bro excuse me bro or I mean
you're using the restroom and seriously
I'm using the restroom and he's right
here writing a letter you know what I
mean so our desk is right here the sink
is right here the bumps are right here
so I'll be using the restroom you need
to be right here writing a letter you
know what I mean and he's like hey
what's up and we're like just this far
away from each other we can like I can
read this letter like that you mean it's
to where now I can actually shut the
door to my restroom lock it and join my
peace enjoy my time you know what I mean
so it's it's it's it's rough you know
um I still
I still my mom thinks it's funny I still
wrote my wrote my uh wrote my uh my
shower my shower roll up like my towel
my boxes my socks and my sandals and I
roll it up and watch this try with the
in the main shower with my boxers on I
wash my boxers and what we call it a
wash one wear one you know what I mean
and we wash our boxes we throw our new
boxes on and we hang you mean we hang
our boxes and to let it dry I mean I'm
still like in a sense very very
institutionalized when it comes to uh
excuse me uh I'm very meticulous uh uh
being neat you know I mean being need
um
excuse me I didn't think I had OCD when
it comes to like cleaning
but like
um like let's just see the blue pen
right there I don't like the way it's
moved so it has to be straight I mean so
I'll move it until I think it's straight
or did that OCD appear when you were in
prison uh yeah yeah I I learned at a
young age is I could you would hear it
down the hall like
okay okay okay I'm sorry I'm crying I'm
like damn what's that for my mind I'm
like I'm gonna damn what the hell's
going on like my son you told me I
always probably he's probably being
standing up or something you know I mean
because like mind you my my Sally was
we're both lifers so as as you learned
uh as as I learned it uh being a life
for sure you got to sit down when you
pee I mean I try to respect because you
don't want piss getting all over the
floor you know because that's really
that's where we walked that's that's our
living room you know what I mean that's
where we want to we can sit on the floor
you know I mean uh um
um I saw I did six I did six months in
solitary confinement in the shoe so I
know I know what it is to be alone
um I got comfortable with that but what
emotions do you go through as your oh
bro spending time in Solitaire you name
it you name it I went from crying to
to it's not my fault I shouldn't be here
but not really I can't I can't believe
nobody who else but myself I mean but
myself because I'm in control of my
actions you know what I mean and did you
feel like you were getting what you
deserved
yes yes I do feel I mean were you
innocent of the second
conviction of the of the of the the time
that you got convicted for yeah yeah
um yeah because uh like I said I I
didn't know I didn't know no one knew he
had a brain aneurysm until the autopsy
showed he did right but they failed to
bring that up in my first my first year
that's why you got out yeah that's the
reason I got out but then the house that
you burned down and the people died in
the house did you feel like you were
somehow deserving of prison time oh yeah
oh yeah I should have I should have been
doing that for a long time ago I mean um
I thank God for that I mean
um that you know he might you know let
you get away I don't know if you're a
believer in God but I am you know let
you get away with certain things until
he's like you know what enough's enough
you know I mean you haven't learned
nothing and you're getting worse I'ma
pump your brakes and I think that's what
he did to me you know what I mean and a
quick reality check like
in a split second you know what I mean
that's right now that you're free
do you feel gratitude for for the
situation you're in now oh for sure dude
I'm grateful and thankful for everything
for everybody who stuck on my side
for everybody that that
never gave up on me you mean uh for my
kids who never give up on me
and I know with the proper guidance and
and the right people in my life
um but my grandma should tell me you
surround yourself you surround yourself
for dogs you're gonna get fleas
I mean so uh you surround yourself with
with the right people
that are are doing the right thing
you'll eventually do the right thing you
know what I mean and that's where I'm at
my life right now you know what I mean
too I wanna
keep those people that that really
aren't going to benefit me in the long
run away from me not in a sense to her I
don't have to cut them out completely I
could be like hey dude what's up how you
doing
to where it's like hey what's up Glenn
come on bro you mean we're having a
social gallery on this go you mean so I
have to be that dude you know I mean not
that oh hell no it comes that drug
addict dude again you know what I mean
he's all strung out
I don't like to be that dude you know I
mean there's I spent many years of my
life having to apologize to people
because
I didn't know how to conduct myself well
uh drunk or under the influence you know
what I mean so dude I haven't drank a
beer and I want to say
honestly now like 13 Years bro I haven't
drank a beer I mean yes I have a problem
with alcohol huh and you used to have a
problem yes yes a real problem alcohol
and and then I all that happened was I
was really intoxicated you know what I
mean and uh where I could have walked
away from it but what they call it beer
balls and it's human came out of me and
all that unfortunate events came past
and and I mean a young man lost his life
that night I mean and
and uh for a long time I couldn't
forgive myself like how can I do that
how can I do that to him like
but then God spoke to me in jail like
you'll see it's not your fault you know
what I mean like it was weird how like
you'd be like oh yeah right dude God
spoke to you no bro he really he really
came to me like you're gonna be okay
you'll see how it's not your fault
and so I just let go let God and and
my Sally for some reason uh uh behind my
back pulled the pure paperwork in
and then uh uh they called me like two
he said they're like hey roll it up
you're transpacking you're going out to
court
it wasn't a hell for what uh for your
appeal
and I'm like nice and I'm looking at
myself and he's laughing under and even
he's laughing on the bottom right I'm
sorry silly I'm sorry bro like you just
you got to go home dude like you gotta
you don't deserve this dude you know I'm
like oh I'm gonna [ __ ] you up Shelly I'm
sorry can I say it on camera I apologize
is that the best day of your life yeah
yeah bro you mean it was Eagles uh I
probably won't see you again uh just
know that I love your life and uh
because if you're interested in I mean
for if you're if you're interested man
they let you go right there from Court
no you're standing bro you don't have to
come back to the jail and get your
property
my son's name is Rudy Acosta from Eric
Church County he's a he's a big your
freedom is because of him yes because of
him because he took the he took the time
to uh mind you he's been there for 45
years prior prior to me getting there
and I was just second Sally he's had
because the rest of his studies he's
killed
you mean so imagine that right yeah
imagine that so
yeah the guy that guy uh
he's been through some stuff you know
what I mean and and it's all because
they don't know how to sit down when
they pee or or or about where they belch
when they're eating you know what I mean
he hates that he hated that part like
bro don't be a pig bro just because you
were busted and and Society they was us
as as as trash doesn't really have to
conduct himself like that you know what
I mean and he had himself at a really
high standard and that's what he helped
me you know what I mean so
so yeah if any uh Freddie uh if you're
watching this one day he's just not I
love you man and thank you for for doing
that for me you know what I mean
crazy what what is your biggest fear
being alone
being alone and because of my uh anger
or because of my addiction you know what
I mean um
um that's my biggest fear dude so if you
have a short temper
uh I used to I used to have a short
temper I drew to 100 real quick and I
mean you name it I'm what do you mean I
can't get to that brick wall I bet you I
can you mean that was my motto I mean I
was nothing can stop me
and uh
I mean I learned my lesson quick I'm
gonna have to mind somebody quick I'm
gonna have to I'm gonna have to mind
somebody
um
but yeah dude I think God and I think
the people that never give up I mean I
mean what's your biggest regret my
biggest regret is uh
that night I mean the night I I got a
fight with that dude I mean um
I had a lot of plans you know I mean uh
your hold huh I'm 35 no you you were how
old at the time uh 11 years old uh uh
I was like 23 23 23 years old yeah yeah
yeah I was 23 and uh
like I said I've been I've been I've
been out two years and I I love her I've
loved every minute I'm not a pro I'm not
on probation
and uh I love it dude I love it my kids
love me and I mean uh
dude when I came home
my my eight channel was taller than me
and I was like ah
okay excuse me okay what's up Dad what's
up dude
through uh through mail through through
pictures you know if you only want them
to come visit me in jail because it's
not a place for them I think I don't
want them to think it's a it's it's cool
oh yeah I want to go visit my dad and
Joe that's not a cool story to tell your
friends it's not that difficult a drug
to quit meth
um no it's not difficult to quit like I
said you surroundings people that are
sober I'm eventually going to get sober
I mean because well you've been out
you've been out two years now yeah I've
been out two years yeah do you think by
now you
put it away and I'm not I'm not like a
strung out on it like I dabble I mean
I'm not like every day I'm not like oh
hold on guys I'm gonna go get high over
here I'll be back you know I mean that's
that's not me like
I'll do a line here and there if if I
know it's going to be along that we're
gonna go party I'll do a line and that's
it I mean I won't touch it I won't I
don't walk around with it with a piece
on me or or a sack on me are you working
now yes I work yeah okay yeah a lot of
people are functioning on that yeah yeah
and it was the scariest one they call
this functioning drug addicts and uh
they say there's a scary the scariest
type because you don't know when they're
gonna when they're gonna snap you know
what I mean um because I'm not condoning
it I'm just saying there are a lot of
people that are working yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah
um
what would you say is the most important
lesson you've learned in your life
the most important question in my life
is is uh
one step at a time you know what I mean
it's it's a it's a life is a marathon
it's not a race and you mean and you
gotta take it you got to take it for
what it is you know I mean it's life
enjoy it you know what I mean because
you don't know when when it can get
snatched away
you know what I mean yeah
all right Glenn thank you so much for
sharing your story thank you so much for
listening to my story I wish you the
best of luck out here yes sir thank you